o pavel eu tenho 37 anos e não tenho
filhos mas quando tiver a minha filha
vai ser top model e meu filho vai ser
jogador de basquete vai julgar no ano de
4 declarações desses a gente ouve
de repente um pouco menos ou o menos
absurdas
a gente ouve no nosso dia a dia dos
nossos amigos vai falando ou eu comprei
uma bola meu filho tem um chute muito
forte muito poderosa com seis anos vai
jogar na seleção brasileira vocês vão
ver a gente ou a mãe falando na minha
filha é verdadeiro cisne
ela tem três anos ela é magra ela fica
na frente de televisão girando o tempo
todo quando passa alguma coisa de dança
ela vai ser do bom sonho vai pra você
então eu sou russos o diretor do bom
show e sonho desde maio provavelmente
passará por mim e se essa experiência
será assunto de de hoje
eu nasci em 1978 em moscou a na frente
do apartamento onde a minha família
morava tinha um pequeno estúdio de piano
então a já com quatro anos eu fiz
primeiro minha primeira aula de música
meu professor me levou para uma escola
um pouquinho maior no bairro
fiz as aulas lá e lá professora também
sugeriu pra fazer pra prestar audição
para a escola central de música eu
passei a audição com seis anos e comecei
a estudar na escola central de música de
moscou uma das mais conceituadas do país
a me formei em piano e logo depois que
me formei como 18 anos e prestei audição
pra teatro bolshoi de moscou e foi um
dos competidores mais novos
a minha famoso no mundo todo um dia
perguntei para meu chefe do próprio
admiro a silva valeriano o senhor senhor
como é que o senhor entrou na área de
dança sempre quis dançar então não tava
brincando com crianças e passou uma
mulher faltava os meninos pra a aula de
dança folclórica me levou junto eu fiz
apesar que meu pai não queria muito
assim eu fui é fazer as aulas logo a
professora percebeu o tamanho do talento
do menino ele foi pra escola
coreográfica e virou um grande banho
quem diria que o grande ídolo ademir
vacila e fundo marinho do século 20 é
considerado pela unesco foi descoberto
pela professora de bairro já preparando
esse palestra conversei com alguns
colegas - á o professor mestre
ele começou a aaa como mergulho
esportivo
depois foi o próprio ação artística não
passou no primeiro teste de patinação
artística e ali
o professor fala porque no tubos e ano
tenta prestar atenção pra escola de balé
ele fez passou e mudou a vida pra sempre
a outra colega minha professor galle ela
ao contrário começou na escola de música
uma das mais conceituadas escolas de
música têm as aulas de coreografia
então a professora dela vi uma pequena e
graciosa menina e falou tenta também
conciliar estudos de coreografia de
dança ela fez viu que tinha muito mais
talento e de vez mudou pra balé e teve
uma carreira brilhante porque estou
contando todas as histórias a existe uma
curiosidade em meus amigos sempre me
perguntam qual é segredo do sucesso dos
russos na área de arte de cultura e
principalmente na área de esporte
aliás existe até um mito parece que o
governo russo de forma impositiva desde
que o bebê nasce e falou você vai ser
campeão campeão de boxe você vai ser um
se vai ser um jogador de xadrez
você vai ser ator de cinema
e como a gente pode ver nesses todas as
histórias na verdade a pessoa
tranquilamente mudava de rob próprio pra
escola profissional de uma atividade
para a outra a mas o que mais importante
sempre muito mais com a volta dos
professores do que com imposição da
família
a gente não pode esquecer que há algum
tempo atrás no mundo todo
a criança era considerada como uma força
de trabalho gratuito
então quanto mais filho melhor
a família vive em seus tempos graças a
deus passarão mais pelo jeito não é na
cabeça de alguns pais
ae tira ele da natação porque ele sempre
chegava por último a cara até que era
até vou pagar as aulas de canto e ele
não tem menor jeito para isso imagina
rubio vou gastar meu dinheiro com isso
muitas vezes mais fala nisso e é existe
realmente uma uma duas formas muito
triste de ver o fio
o primeiro é um desejo frustrado do pai
ah eu não fiz então você vai fazer você
vai ter que conseguir ou muitas vezes a
vendo o filho como um fundo de
investimento
eu vou ficar velho é ali que tu é pagar
as minhas contas
então há como diretor de uma escola
técnica onde a 70% dos alunos formados
trabalham na área de dança
eu afirmo com toda certeza no rat como
programar o sucesso
na verdade você pode fazer que é seu
filho bira o médico
mas qual vai ser o custo de escolas vai
ser preço pra que o kalil me falava os
sapatos que fica bem numa numa pessoa
são pequenas para a outra
não existe uma receita de vida que sirva
para todos
e pior a o sucesso ele é medido de forma
estranha às vezes na cabeça dos pais
quando quero que minha filha seja uma
simples buzina eu quero que ela vá
embora num show e mesmo eu não quero que
ela das com todo mundo no corpo de baile
como colegas não que não é lá na frente
como solista
eu quero ela como cartaz o espetáculo no
facebook no instagram um filme bom sobre
isso e cisne negro onde toda a tragédia
e começa quando a menina passa na frente
ver um cartaz que não é ela ela quer
estar lá ela tem a cobrança dentro dela
e cobrança da família e tudo termina com
tanta tragédia é uma ambição não
acompanhada pelo nível técnico pela
inteligência emocional mas do outro lado
de outro lado existe um outro perigo
às vezes mais falou assim ah eu não vou
escolher pra ele que ele vai fazer meu
filho é pai
deixei ele brincar deixa de se criar ter
infância a não vou escolher ele vai ter
18 anos ali ele vai escolher o que ele
vai fazer é não escolher por ele é
verdade só que desse forma a gente
importante dizer que a gente não aumenta
a possibilidade da criança escolher e
diminui porque tem várias áreas a gente
pode exercitar a ginástica rítmica aonde
se você não começar cedo começar com
quatro anos você perde totalmente a
chance de se profissionalizar a então
que mais gente ouve no bolshoi se eu
tivesse começado cedo a ser minha
família me apoiasse a seu pai soubesse
que é balé é bom começar com 89 anos
então eu tenho também uma história da
família
para exemplificar isso eu tenho um
sobrinho é filho da minha irmã que é tem
um grande talento pra violino ele mesmo
com quatro anos que estocar aquele
instrumento só que ele foi estudar numa
escola como hobby e minha irmã ela faz
sempre falava ou não quero que eles com
estudos numa escola oficial estudos
oficiais estragam criança bota dentro da
caixinha assim ele vai perder todo o
talento dele falou o que lhe deixem de
fazer isso que deixa ele também testar a
audição para uma escola
profissionalizante
porque se ele passar numa escola aonde
são 20 pessoas por vaga pode acreditar
que é a vida escolheu pra ele tentar se
profissionalizar
agora sendo passado deixa ele lá num
tranquilo
ela deixou de fazer com seis anos ele
passou na escola agora vai estudar de
forma profissionalizante todos os dias
mas que o exemplo pra mim essa 11 uma
situação bem tranquila porque mesmo é
ele
agora com seis anos fazendo seis horas
de violino
quem falou que ele tem obrigação de ser
músico
quem falou que ele tinha obrigação de se
formar na escola
pode ser que vai passar um ano ele é
tranquilamente vai falar onu que eu não
quero tocar um outro instrumento que eu
vou fazer de repente uma outra coisa na
vida
ah a gente não pode esquecer que a
educação musical no caso
nós simplesmente criação de um músico
profissional mas criação de uma pessoa
com as suas características inerentes
quantas pessoas que em algum momento
dançaram fizeram uma dança hoje não são
bailarinos quantas pessoas fizeram
música e hoje não são músicos
eu mesmo mesmo trabalhando como a arte
hoje exerço muito mais papel de
administrador do que de artista
quantas pessoas pintam os quadros como
hobby
aliás daqui uns 20 anos a gente nem sabe
que vai ser o hub que vai ser área
profissional
o nelson rodrigues falava com sorte você
atravessa o mundo sem a sorte você na
outra vez nem a rua é em verdade nós
temos oito alunos que se formaram aqui
em joinville e se realizar um grande
sonho e trabalho por exemplo oito alunos
trabalham na rússia 4 a 4 ex alunos
trabalham hoje no próprio teatro bolshoi
de moscou que um ápice a mostrando que
sonho é possível
então pedimos que desistir dos sonhos
mas se que o sonho não pode se tornar
posições que procura um propósito e
trazendo tudo o que fazem é importante
lembrar que sonha se constrói
os poucos que se vive no momento no dia
a dia e não é um ponto o a longe e eu
como diretor da escola em joinville isso
tão feliz por pessoas que se formaram e
que hoje trabalha na área de dança das
melhores companhias do brasil e do mundo
como também por outros felizes que ele
vá que ele é uma dança para a vida toda
então matriculam seus filhos para
atividades complementares apoio às
iniciativas deles a valorizam as
peculiaridades deles
e podem ter certeza que o que mais
agradeço à minha família não quis um dia
eles escolheram a música pra mim mas que
depois não puseram muita expectativa não
fazer um desses três muito cobrados e
que fez que o amor à música pra sempre
e pra encerrar a gostaria de fazer
justamente isso eu gostaria de tocar uma
música que eu com posses semana a uma
ex-aluna nossa bandeira no canadá
lucila ela sofreu um acidente grave
ficou dez dias em coma e só abre os
olhos
ontem então junto com o bailarino é
tonys a gente queria fazer uma singela
homenagem para ela oscila
hum
bom